it gets worse ladies and gentlemen we
got this story from the Daily Mail
the West has brought humankind to the
brink of nuclear Armageddon with its
decision to use depleted uranium ammo in
Ukraine says Russia's U.S Envoy as it
turns out Britain is using depleted
depleted uranium tank Busters
and so Russia is basically saying this
is the doorstep of nuclear war now I
don't I don't know is is the pleated
uranium radioactive it is yeah it is
really not extremely but enough enough
of it in high enough concentrations it
happened in Iraq they shot it it's in
the dust under the sand a lot of people
were getting sick from like Gulf War
syndrome they were blaming I think it
was Gulf War syndrome I'm not sure if
they were using depleted uranium in the
first Gulf War or not but uh people were
coming back sick and they think a lot of
it's your radiation the British defense
Ministry confirmed on Monday that it
would provide Ukraine with
armor-piercing rounds containing
depleted uranium
is a nuclear weapon you and you can say
tongue-in-cheek hey you stupid idiot no
it's not but listen the Russian minister
is acknowledging it but consider it
nuclear armaments maybe not nuclear
weaponry as considered but they consider
it nuclear but and that's all that
matters they can now as they are
starting to do use this as justification
for the expansion into nuclear warfare
and this doesn't mean icbms because
people need to understand I think the
first thing we're going to see is
probably nuclear artillery which is
they're going to load up a Howitzer or
some kind of artillery they're going to
fire a nuclear shell with a decently
large payload it's not going to be a
Megaton bomb or anything like that but
it's going to be massively devastating
these are very very powerful weapons so
the first you they can argue nuclear war
has already started with the use of
armor-piercing depleted uranium
and then the U.S will say that's not
true nobody thinks that's what nuclear
weapons means but of course Russia and
China are going to be like this isn't
these are nuclear weapons this is
radioactive stuff yeah this says here
depleted uranium both regular uranium
and depleted uranium uh in their
immediate Decay products submit Alpha
and beta particles and a small amount of
gamma radiation that's from EC well
there you go right there radioactive
weapons so what what comes next Russia
says well if they're using nuclear
weapons we need to respond in kind then
we get lower yield nuclear artillery
massive explosions rocking Ukraine then
what the west escalates and uses
low-yield missiles I think there's also
a concern that the dust that's created
by the depleted uranium is breathed in a
lot of it's really when it's in your
body that can do a lot of damage
um what's happening is they built tanks
out of armor that are created with
depleted uranium because it's so dense
you can't pierce it with a lot of
weapons so they need to make depleted
uranium ammo in order to pierce the
depleted uranium armor and then the ammo
ends up in the dust in the dirt
underneath your feet that's the problem
I mean I gotta be honest
this picture of how it works really cool
you know this gigantic artillery shell
look at this it's basically a gigantic
cartridge like a bullet with a depleted
uranium tail fin with a Sabo around it
and then it fires Sabo disengages and
then rips through with a point it's two
times denser it's nearly twice as dense
as lead that's why they use it it's they
say it's nearly Unstoppable because of
its its density so once it gets
propelled the inertia is just too
powerful just rips through everything
I mean that sounds pretty badass to be
honest it's just horrifying yeah for a
video game right right but for real life
it's it's not great the reason they have
like the hag and the war crimes and
things because like if you annihilate a
country with depleted uranium you're
making it unlivable essentially if the
ground's peppered with depleted uranium
good good luck growing crops and raising
a family on top of that so it's like
salting Earth I mean it's it's
definitely it's a heinous War crime in
my opinion but out of desperation and
armored tanks that can't be penetrated
they've had no arguably other choice I I
I think we we may see some kind of uh I
think world war three
um I don't know how or when but I think
it for one reason because all of the oil
producing nations are teaming up China
is working these deals to do oil deals
uh trade in in one as opposed to the
dollar and the United States and NATO
will never allow that I I I I don't know
what do you think Matt I kind of feel
like military industrial complex will be
salivating at the thought of an
opportunity to go to Industrial scale
Warfare and or Beyond and the us is
going to be like we're not going to let
these countries do this we will blow
them up if we have to because we're not
going to lose yeah I think I think they
would love to have another War
regardless of the consequences for
people but one of one of the most
frustrating things about this is we're
we're escalating while we're
demilitarizing our ability to produce
energy and this I actually have friends
in Ukraine and and in in that whole area
my wife and I go go speak to free market
groups in all of these countries and and
our point was why aren't you guys
producing energy you're you're Banning
fracking you're you're destroying your
economies and and you're you're
basically made yourself completely
dependent on your enemies sources of
energy and all of this green stuff
there's a green deal in in Europe that
that has already been implemented
um this is the most destabilizing policy
that empower hours really bad guys and I
happen to be a Libertarian that thinks I
think Putin is a horrible guy I think he
is a criminal for invading Ukraine but I
also think that Ukraine is an incredibly
corrupt country and I think the United
States has no business in this because
if you want to protect yourself from
Russia
do something for yourself like clean up
your own country allow for the
production of energy and if you can't
produce your own energy allow for a
robust markets that'll allow you to buy
the energy you need and not wait for
Russia to shut off the pipeline
this is not rocket science they haven't
done it so Ukraine is Banning fracking
no Ukraine doesn't do that but but
Europe and I see it Germany and and the
UK and places like that well I think
it's it's because
you know when I look at the internal
conflict in the United States I can only
assume it is intentionally driven by our
enemies like the woke left I look at
what they believe and what they're
fighting for and how insane it is and
how destructive it is and how it is it
is a major component in in the victories
for China
and I'm like I kind of feel like they're
doing it on purpose like with Tick Tock
things like that they talk about the
Russian disinfo campaigns and all that
stuff and I'm like well we know China's
been hacking and attacking us with cyber
warfare for a long time I wouldn't be
surprised if a large component of the
culture war is intentionally driven not
and they did talk about this with Russia
they said it wasn't necessarily intended
to win an election it was intended to so
division in the United States I'm
willing to bet China's doing that to a
great degree Tick Tock is I watched a
video earlier where this woman was like
I am a bird I am I am a bird I am
trapped in a human body and like that's
the kind of thing that Tick Tock
promotes
so if you have people in this country
who are of sound mind saying we cannot
allow China to do the things they're
doing with the weaker Muslims
etc etc and then you're on a committee
with one other person who goes but I'm
actually a bird so I'd like to move this
here to talk about what we're going to
do about bird rights and you're going to
be like what undivided power with this
guy China the Chinese Communist Party
knows we cannot function politically if
half of our political system thinks
they're animals or weird things and
doesn't make any sense and that's where
we're being bogged we have weight
strapped to our ankles I don't see how
we win this one
I I don't know man
if the US is on the verge of civil war
or in one or if the Democratic party is
just their whole die on this hill moment
is removing the testicles of children
then it's just like okay I guess
fortunately I don't think the goal is to
win I I think it's more to coexist like
there's no real end game in diplomatic
geopolitics it's just about can we
survive together and Thrive together
that can be done but it can be done
through trade it's primarily trade who's
who I I wish that's what the world was
doing yeah no one's doing that
that is like how can we work together
against our common enemy against our
common entities or in a way that allows
me to continue doing the things I like I
think the problem is you know there are
a lot of countries that feel morally
compelled to insert themselves into
issues and say you can't live that way
or part of our Doctrine is that we have
to expand our power I mean it doesn't
have the isolationist boundaries that
maybe we would like it to if we could
just all stay within our own countries
and you know cooperate when necessary it
might be a different detail but
geopolitical geopolitical diplomacy I
think there's a bunch of Bad actors but
I I don't I'm not as afraid of of Russia
and China I think their economies are a
house of cards as well and my argument
is if we would get our house in order if
our allies would get our house in order
we would not be vulnerable to their
Shenanigans because they don't have the
resources to do what they do and I could
you know quote Michael malice's new
white pill book and pointing out that
that top-down systems collapse yeah
um well I I agree but that's why I'm
saying I think the internal conflict is
the problem we're facing right if we
can't but it's on us right we got to fix
it
well not just at this table yes but
Americans got to get their act together
but but I but I feel like that's the
attack they're living against us making
sure we can like Tick Tock is a huge
component right now you've got the
Democrats trying to preserve it and the
Republicans are barely doing anything
about it they don't even know what the
argument is yeah I think Banning it's
not right at first I'm liking it
absolutely because then it would lead to
someone Banning Twitter and you don't
want to start Banning companies from the
states I mean free the software code if
you want to see what they're doing and
what the algorithm is doing Fair Point
It's gotta it's got to be like an and
Elon might save us and I don't I'd hate
to put all of our eggs in in one
Billionaire's basket but the solution to
tick tock is is an alternative that's
not nuts that's not manipulative that
allows the things we like speech and and
argument and all the things that America
has built on as opposed to that crazy
manipulation and the problem has been is
that that these Tech platforms have been
centralized and basically speech has
been dictated by the FBI ncia who are
you going to vote for in 2024
I don't know yet would you vote for
Trump I'm not saying like you should I'm
just asking like would you consider um
you know I was going to until he screwed
up locked down so badly I don't think I
can forgive that that's a good point man
uh I'm I'm pretty much for Trump right
now we'll see what changes DeSantis is I
feel like it's shown to be a big letdown
I would I would prefer Dave Smith you
know if like if someone said name a
person and they'll be president I'll go
Dave Smith assuming he wants to be
hasn't announced yet in in all practical
reality you know I probably end up
voting for Trump what do you think
ramaswamy
um I I like a lot of what he's doing the
ESD stuff is fantastic I don't I don't
and maybe I'm agreeing with you on this
I don't think you cut off trade with
China I think you outperformed China
and and he wants to he wants to isolate
our enemies through through state power
and I want to isolate our enemies from
outperforming them
and but I think he's he's quite
interesting and and quite provocative in
a lot of ways he's probably doing what
Dave wants to do which is change the
conversation
um and this is a big debate within the
libertarian party are we running to win
are we running to change the narrative
so that we can actually talk about some
of these things that the two parties
never talk about and I think I think
both but you got to build right so
obviously with the libertarian party you
got a lot of buildings going to happen
there's a percentage threshold that's
got to be met which means you've got to
be serious contenders but during in the
meantime the victories you get is
changing the conversation yeah so you
know what do we got to do to get to a
point where Dave Smith's on a debate
stage with Biden and Trump that would be
tremendous it may be fantastic they're
never going to let them on the stage
they keep changing the rules if he gets
closer they're just going to say you
know what you need 20 of the polls to be
on the stage but the point is with with
all of these platforms
um you know how many times do we have to
point out that Joe Rogan is bigger than
all three networks right before election
combined and point out that if we want
to have that conversation outside of
corporate media we can do that now yeah
and I also think that if Joe Rogan ran
for president he'd probably win he'd
probably beat them both I'd vote for him
now see I would vote for Joe I think a
lot of people would because he's like
you listen to him and he's talking about
cultural issues which the right agrees
with but he's still somewhat of a
moderate Lefty kind of guy so you gotta
get you kind of get a compromise but
he's just so popular yeah I'm not saying
he's going to run or he should run I'm
just saying that kind of personal
connection and and and and gravitas is
what you need I'm I'm I'm thinking Trump
I think Trump's got a lot of bad about
him but I view him as a slight not
positive mostly on foreign policy I
don't completely blame him for the
lockdowns I somewhat blame him for the
lockdowns I think he surrounded himself
with really bad people I'm also thinking
now
you know what man
I'm willing to get him in the next four
years if we can see more of that foreign
policy if it's more of secure our
borders bring jobs back here and get our
troops out of these other countries make
NATO pay its fair share all right well
you know then I'll take what we get
domestically but I think the economy
will be good and I think he'll do a
better job well here's here's the thing
like as you continue to dig into the
sources of gain a function uh
experiments and all that crazy Mad
Science that fauci and a niaid was doing
that's actually a biosecurity program
and there's a reason I suspect why Rand
Paul has switched to the homeland
security committee because if you want
to get to the bottom of covid and you
want to get to the bottom of gain of
function and you want to find out
whether or not American taxpayers
actually financed the creation of a
virus that created so much Global
disruption you got to go after the
National Security State this is not the
healthcare industrial complex it's
National Security so these things are
very much related so who whoever is
going to be the next president is going
to have to take on that and this is some
place where Trump failed thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time